with the most extraordinary actor and
entrepreneur Naomi Watts and she's about
to add masseuse to her credentials
because she's going to give me a face
massage first of all how did I get so
lucky
I just what kind of massage am I getting
okay I'm gonna give you a Stripes facial
oh my God some of our products these are
all sustainable packaging glass
containers with refillables and this is
called the power move and it's
foreign
and it's called that because it's packed
with really powerful ingredients
and we've got five different hyaluronic
acids in here along with ectoin and
squalene which are specifically
powerful because they're great for
hydration from menopausal or
perimenopausal skin
yes what happens when we lose estrogen
is we we become more dehydrated and we
also become sensitive I feel
um crazy I really do I I cried this
morning over air conditioning that's I
know that's the perimenopause well it is
perimenopause is the hardest part of it
you feel like you're losing yourself
lately I I I feel like my body my belly
is full of like some type of I don't
know I would call it cortisol or cottage
cheese I'm not sure
which it is but like it's not my belly
and it doesn't matter what I eat yeah
and it's it's exactly right it hits at
different times in different ways
everybody has different symptoms
um you know you've I'm looking at your
hair and I see there's nothing wrong
with that hair and me I have lost so
much hair really yeah
um and yeah have you lost your mind too
I lost my mind and for me I was I
actually
hit perimenopause it didn't even know
that that was a word at the time I got
told that I was probably close to
menopause at the age of 36 just when I
was trying to have children and it it
sent me into a complete panic
and mercifully I was able to get
pregnant naturally oh Naomi I'm so glad
that you are an ambassador and a guider
to all of us women yeah we're we're
um we've just got to end the stigma and
the shame and and the confusion and put
our hands up for ourselves and be our
best Advocates and say how do I make
this the best it can be how do I take
agency and when you have a community and
you have the education you are going to
be so much better set up for it and this
is not just for your you who is in Perry
um but it's for the generation behind
you who needs to get better prepared and
if we have the preparation and we're
ahead of it it's going to be so much
more manageable it's it's natural it's a
just a phase it's a transition and we
get to the other side it's gonna be okay
I mean I didn't think I could love you
anymore
but I do and this is a moment of my life
I will never forget and I will be using
your skincare because I truly
truly noticed a difference in my skin
using stripes oh and I'm a beauty junkie
too thank you Naomi so much for this
most meaningful spiritual Soulful fun
cool and awesome like hang thank you
thank you congratulations on Stripes
trust me every woman go out there and
get this you need this and then please
watch The Watcher which premieres
October 13th on Netflix
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign